alors que le procès des attentats du 13
novembre 2015 débute dès mercredi la
question de l'indemnisation des victimes
fait débat et les régler par le fonds de
garantie des victimes auxquelles chaque
français cotisent lors de la signature
d'un contrat d'assurance habitation ou
automobile ce fonds a versé jusqu'ici
près de 140 millions d'euros de
provisions et d'indemnités 1702 des 2600
un dossier sont finalisés mais certaines
victimes ont accepté un montant qu'elle
jugeait trop faible parce qu'elles
n'avaient plus l'énergie de contester
705 personnes n'ont pas accepté l'offre
proposée elle ou d'autres victimes ont
dû se battre pour que le préjudice soit
reconnu comme explique l'avocat de
parties civiles samia maktouf c'est un
parcours de combattant ne serait ce que
pour remplir les formulaires pour
répondre aux costauds questionnaire pour
subir la contre expertise comme comme si
il s'agissait d'un banal accident de
voiture il faut prouver réellement le
préjudice se battre pour que quelqu'un
comme walid puisse avoir
personne quelqu'un pour l'assister dans
sa douche parce qu'il ne peut plus
prendre sa douche et il ne peut l'avoir
que pendant deux heures et a beaucoup
qui ne bénéficient pas d'habitation
adapté sans ascenseur on est en train de
se battre pour que la mairie de paris
octroie à ses victimes du terrorisme un
logement digne sur les réseaux sociaux
dans la presse ou dans des lettres
ouvertes de nombreuses victimes ont
ainsi détailler leur calvaire la tante
démesurée et la remise en question de
leur souffrance lors des expertises en
fait d'accompagnement je n'ai reçu
jusqu'à ce jour de vos services qu objet
ctions langage administratif opacité de
fonctionnement absence d'engagement à
croire que tout est fait pour ne pas me
verser ce qui est dû et donc m'enfoncer
dans le marasme administratif le
désoeuvrement existentielle et la
précarité matérielle qui est devenue ma
vie depuis le 13 je garde un souvenir
très traumatisant de mon entretien avec
leur psy qui m'a mis sur le carreau
jaune a été sorti en larmes à faire
plusieurs crises d angoisse quand j'en
ai parlé à une employée du fonds elle
m'a demandé
je n'exagère est pas un peu classe dans
la majorité des cas le fonds tient
compte de chaque préjudice et en mineurs
parfois certains un peu dans une logique
d'assurance traditionnels qui
chercherait à faire des économies
catherine svarc une avocate spécialisée
préjudice corporel évoque les victimes
en évaluation souvent elles ont
l'impression de ne pas être crues il
n'est pas normal que des victimes
arrivent à vous indiquer qu' elles sont
malheureuses qu'elles sont qu'elle perde
pied à l'issue de l'expertisé parce
qu'on ne les a pas crues parce que l on
a l'impression d'avoir été maltraité
pour nous pour les avocats on se bat
énormément pour qu'il y ait une
bientraitance des victimes ou titre des
polémiques certaines victimes évoquant
leur souffrance ont dû subir les
commentaires critiques d'un utilisateur
anonyme sur twitter en mai dernier une
enquête a prouvé qu'il s'agissait d'un
adjoint d'un des directeurs du fonds de
garantie qui a depuis été écartée le
fonds qui n'avait pas besoin de cela
fait donc face au tollé une concertation
nationale sur l'accompagnement et
l'indemnisation des victimes a été
initiée par la déléguée
interministérielle à l'aide aux victimes
frédérique calandra en juillet nous nous
sommes adressés à son cabinet pour
connaître l'avancement des travaux sans
réponse julien qui le directeur du fonds
de garantie des victimes s'est défendu
des critiques dans la presse il
reconnaît que le meilleur des systèmes
d'indemnisation ne sera jamais à la
hauteur des souffrances des victimes
six ans après les faits le dispositif
reste en effet plutôt éloigné de la
perfection